[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
we talk about whatever we want and today
we have Meg squats here she's a fitness
youtuber and a strength trainer and
that's why she squats coach yes how come
her name's Meg squats and that Meg
deadlift or make bench because or make
curls I did a bodybuilding show and I
got I got shredded and then I got really
fat after it and I still wanted to go to
the gym but the only thing that I did
for like two months was squat why
because I was jiggling around too much
with everything else
pictures of when I was shredded oh yeah
yeah if you you were not Jacob but for
me I went from like being really small
like the smallest I've ever been since
like preteen years to like gaining 30
pounds like that
wow how fast like in a month no I may be
even less than that like a couple of
weeks I was just like oh [ __ ] I think
you just retained so well first of all
you start eating finally and then you
retain so much water and you just feel
bloated all the time and then I was like
in denial is like oh maybe I'm just
bloated but no that's cute for people
that don't know can you walk people
through like what the last three weeks
of a bodybuilding prep looks like in
terms of like how your training what
your diet looks like maybe even sleep
maybe losing your period maybe a hair
fall enough know the dedication
crosseyed a little bit sometimes
all right you lose your sex drive you
forgot that one true well cuz you're
basically starving your body to get
ripped right so to lower that body fat
percentage what what what's the
competition like body fat percentage to
actually be good enough to compete I
mean anyone can compete like you there
so to be like top-tier not me though I
definitely wasn't top tier but I still
went through a lot of those things like
I didn't know what I was doing through
this whole time but it's like you start
dieting and you have only so many
calories and then as you get closer and
closer they just keep going down so you
like already start maybe twelve weeks
out and you're like
[ __ ] I'm dieting and then it just keeps
getting worse and worse almost like two
or three weeks out what was your
calories at oh I don't remember but I
remember like the week before maybe I
was hot like 1,200 and that means your
calorie intake yeah yeah the amount of
calories dependent mother 1200 yeah it
was your food like reading I did if it
fits your macros like for the last week
what was like the food a lot of yeah
yeah yeah boring stuff chicken sloppy I
mean I eat a lot of that stuff now a bag
of air I had very few cards so I
couldn't have like rice or anything just
a vegetable so it's like a three month
fast basically cuz you're just eating
based like I don't know like a meal a
day or some [ __ ] what is that 1200
calories you're not saying you have to
Train still give you enough energy to
train so what do you get that energy
from like do you rely on happiness I'm
sure I was like really caffeinated but
also I was still going through like
beginner gains so I was still later
beginner game that wasn't oh yeah
you had that we got that so tell me what
is it it's like one at the beginning now
we've all been lifting for a while Bart
and I Gio - maybe been lifting for so
many so available it's so like when
you're at a certain point you your gains
train just like slows down and it
becomes hard and hard as I make progress
yeah and then you enter games when you
just skyrocket yeah the beginning for
example maybe in three months you can
add like 20 pounds or squat now it might
take someone like three years to add 20
pounds respond yeah we're in the
beginning you might gain like right away
five pounds of muscle but then after
five years of training like adding on
the extra like quarter pound oh yeah
then how do you determine muscle from
fat like pounds of muscle and pounds of
fat because people usually estimate or
though I like have you ever seen her
trainer they were like yeah this is my
client Robbie
he gained 40 pounds of muscle and he
lost he lost 30 pounds of fat it's like
okay so he gained ten pounds I don't
know you know but you can do like body
fat testing you can get but a lot of
times people will look at just make sure
the real [ __ ] though not like the one
you go to like 24 and kind of squeeze
the machine like a pool thing where you
walk in and in day you got those ones or
you sit in something that looks like
like an MRI kind of thing and it scans
your body but that's a scan Oh like a
x-ray I did that and then I'll you see
er just my boob implants like just these
[ __ ] round thing they can measure a
couple things your body fat percentage
of Waterway your bone density isn't four
full of [ __ ] - or not
oh [ __ ] adds a lot of pounds though they
should measure fat fat people by the
sound of their voice because I swear to
god fat chicks are louder than anybody
[Laughter]
there's a lot of awesome voices coming
from the baritone fat peoples yes I've
seen a lot of skinny like a hundred
pound dudes with big-ass [ __ ] Adam's
apples voices really yeah we're talking
about the chicks who are like that's my
[ __ ] friend [ __ ] like I will take
a bullet for my [ __ ] friend it
doesn't matter like I'll do it every
time a good friend and then then all of
her friends like aw I hate this [ __ ]
and the guys always like - God
don't worry about it it's fine I'll
never talk to your friend again in my
life the body oh yeah oh yeah I full-on
stopped seeing this chick because her
fat friend like oh my god in my face it
was like if you ever hurt her I swear to
God I was like because of this
conversation I will never see your
friend again because you're that
annoying
I don't know good question she sounds
like she's drunk like all the time they
often do let's go
um so I I found out about you because
you were kind of like an all love like
the fitness circles and stuff and oh my
collage and that's tight um so when you
came in were you already thinking like
obviously you were like in the fitness
thing right but we're you thinking like
wow this is pretty cool and like I'm
getting like people really interested in
what I'm doing so I'm gonna start
posting more of my workouts on IG and
then whoa that's pretty cool like
people are asking questions let me go
into YouTube was it like that yeah kind
of like even when I was really young I
always thought I wanted to be famous I
don't know how but I knew that that's
what I was gonna do and I guess five
years ago like Fitness YouTube that was
one like Nikki Black Adder and Christian
guzmán started like the vlog fitness and
there was obviously more people than
that but I would watch that
and Bart Kwan comedian fitness guru Bart
Kwan newly signed us if I do you have
true the most troubling branding I've
seen so I watch those guys and I'd be
like wow their life looks so cool so I
would just try to do some sort of
fitness blogging with an angle of well
I'm training for strength and it's not
like me competing for a body moving or
anything anymore
I'm powerlifting but before that I was
just posting like Pete rubbish kind of
videos like just me lifting just going
half and like upload the clip of me
lifting and that's it like my first
videos are just like squat there's no
sound there's no narration there's
nothing nope
oh [ __ ] kind of say I find it very
refreshing that you're like I'm in this
to be famous dude I'll do it through
this angle I'm get famous that's tight
it's the new generation though it's
awesome is it yeah but there's no other
because people are so self-righteous
nobody will cop to it though yeah I
wanted to help people get to help it
with you I mean I definitely want to
help you I don't know what my followers
are growing she's a side effect of tear
Fame rise right here yeah I do remember
being like really young and like just
knowing I'm for sure gonna be same I
don't know did you guys feel like yeah I
was like I was like I'm a I'm a talked
to a lot of people I have visions I'm
[ __ ] I'm like sleeping and I wake up
and I'm like I'm gonna talk to a lot of
[ __ ] people I see an audience I don't
go back to see for me I can relate to
that feeling because when I was little
and it wasn't a lot at all it was like
database it kind of felt like um you
know how you kind of when you're a kid
you kind of sense when you're about to
be in trouble like that feeling of like
that ings I
after you pat someone you're like I
think it's coming so for me it was
nothing that I actually did that
warranted that feeling but for some
reason I always had this like deep down
internal feeling like one day a lot of
people around the world are gonna know
me and I don't know why and that scares
me that's exactly it didn't scare me I
was just like waiting for it I thought I
was gonna be a singer but if you heard
me singing at karaoke you'd be like
she's alright like you wouldn't you
wouldn't say like oh that's embarrassing
like she's okay she said that she's like
that top 80 proof you wouldn't be
discovered you wouldn't be like oh my
god I need to sign you right now never
was it something like you're in the
shower and you're like oh [ __ ] I got in
the car and I thought I thought that I
could sound just like whoever see just
like this vid that's my wife to rap when
Nikki's doing rap like Eminem rap but it
looks so [ __ ] cute she has no idea
it's not hard for it looks like a little
kids doing it like a bunny
that's [ __ ] cute she's thing is you
follow that [ __ ] and all I can't put
hands on the wheel please Jesus
we have kids that's gonna be like you
can't do this [ __ ] this is my stupid
life do it more do it that you and your
kid I mean hurt your kid are gonna be
doing it yeah you could teach my kid
squats dude I don't think I know how to
do with a successful squad oh you didn't
forget well here's the thing that part
of the gym is very intimidating what
part the squat the squat area those
people are [ __ ] dialed in bro they
are cut off and the rest of the human
race guys wearing [ __ ] squat goggles
and chicks I go to the gym now I have to
go on like past month o'clock
guys got squat goggles guys got [ __ ]
his ear buds and [ __ ] they do prepare
they prepare the phoniest [ __ ] that they
smell wipe your hands down
I like squat goggles sometimes I have
people slap them yeah exactly yes and
then me and then they pull up pick up
the bar and then they drop it midair and
like the thing sounds like an earthquake
one-off or it sounds like a [ __ ] pipe
bomb or everyone in the whole gym looks
over at them but they're so dialed in
then give a [ __ ] no no this is a funnier
cuz it's like at 24-hour fitness or yeah
yeah yeah it's intense man felt so cool
during those six months that I was
weightlifting I was just like okay I
know how to set up my bar I know how to
set up the whole rack and everything I
go up good I'm good on rack
you see if she even likes a thumbs in
right yeah where did you start up a
fight your max quality was a 65 pounds
or something I was like 135 after like
six that's really good yeah you doubled
it yeah these were like go at every
direction in the beginning I need to do
that and then now it's like well now
it's back down by subscribe but now it's
like back to negative I haven't done it
in a long time cuz I went back and I
ended up doing box jumps and I like
scraped a chunk out of my shake and
since then I got you got soft ones now I
know you told me that but so I know
there's beginner gains are there
beginner losses like I feel like I've
been a beginner loss do you you look
like if you've been I think that the
stat is for every year or something that
you train the amount of time you can
take off is a day per year before your
body starts going into like an attribute
mode yeah so like for example you've
been training for seven years outside of
a normal T load you could take seven
days off before your body starts getting
rid of the muscle well you've only been
training for one year you can only
afford to take one day off after a
normal DLO before your body starts
bringing that muscle what does that mean
one day off like if you workout three
times a week so like if you've been
training for a year consistently every
day every day whatever gains you've had
at that point
I'm your regularly scheduled break in
layman's terms the next day that you
take off your body is already gonna
start breaking down the muscle you just
don't need it no more is what it's
saying
mm did your muscle cost so much it's not
energy efficient for your body that's
why I watch that show survivor and the
most muscly dudes can't do [ __ ] on that
show and they get hungry and they die
yep same things they're [ __ ] but
everyone always talks about like all
those guys are muscle and [ __ ] they
always thought that was Bart why not he
was training for boot camp
yeah well it's cuz you use your muscles
so much dude I noticed that I've gotten
weaker since I started doing this [ __ ]
because I get stronger and the things I
can lift but the amount of time I can
lift them is less because of [ __ ]
your muscles are sore from yesterday oh
yeah yeah one time I tried the army PFT
yeah the one that they currently have
and you have to run a mile
so I maxed like my situps and my
push-ups and then I failed the mile oh
you failed it I failed the cut out for a
mile I don't even know I think it's like
14 minutes no I was I was happy because
I used it as some clickbait for the
video and it's my best video oh no it's
very straightforward she's saying she's
done well it was good for the story cuz
it's like you know it's true I am really
efficient I like squatting and benching
anti lifting but if I had to run a mile
to save my life or past the PFT then I
would have a hard time doing that cuz
you're a fighter not a fighter that's
why you don't need a run you'll squat
the [ __ ] out of your enemy
listen my friend and he had all the
chicks and JK except for maybe two of
them [ __ ] go bobbing for popsicles
with blindfolds on and then we're all
like what do you do with that he's like
what I'm just having a box but I don't
get [ __ ] family chat another why why
doing this click bake [ __ ] and he still
goes
No so we had the girls blindfolded we
were in that video and then there's like
cooking like popsicle like big sticks
and they're like trying to do bikinis
Family Channel
well most fans follow because of his
daughter and his wife and the family
thing we thought it would be a great
idea to do this do you won't cop to it
yes straight up just like oh yeah do the
flip indicators awesome you're on my
cell we will we appreciate it
I never thought I'd be honored for click
vaiting but you're honorable for being
honest yeah you're real that you're all
era on are all for well you do have to
tell a story right like when you're
doing those kind of videos defend
yourself here yeah we're just giving you
props because we all do it and would you
like to be in a row guilty of pretending
as if we're not trying to do QuickBase
we're not above it no we're good
good I got a buddy who pretends like
he's not in the game and I'm like dude
you're just doing the game every time
well I won't say him the game it's
probably someone very very famous they
try to be above the game but they play
the game yeah like saying that they
pretend as if they're able then to do
quick bait or whatever they do things
honorably like I don't do that [ __ ] but
he did I'm like brother you doing the
[ __ ] right now
yeah oh god I want to know no but I
don't know I'll set up a trio if you
guys enjoy paint job right now Steve is
gonna say check it out if you want I'll
put it on patreon no no you have to get
patreon before you know that's a good
have to go to know Steve don't say it
okay I won't sit I only allow this on
patreon I I will tell it all I'm trying
to make money here I get it let's put it
on patreon
that now that's how you click bait
that's how you [ __ ] click that right
yeah you see that that's gonna tell us
but he's gonna tell us on patreon you
know go into desertion box below click
that link and go join the picture of
support and you'll hear who Steve is
[ __ ] gonna burn out and we're all
gonna be bobbing for fudgesicle soup
it's the water bottle challenge
it's it's it only makes money if it's
not not me
you know like I'll lose my yard yeah
maybe yeah maybe maybe you know that's
the quick bait that they throw back they
cut it back throw it back in the water
that gets us unsubscribed yeah yeah
that's bycatch yeah so funny yeah I love
the honesty though because it's
refreshing you know like I think
especially now with people just trying
to be such [ __ ] heroes you know and
they're like oh no no no I'm not doing
this for this I'm doing it for people
late especially the [ __ ] fake
pranksters and a social experiment
people yes can expose people expose the
hypocrisy of human beings
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here dude
unbelievable did you do other kind of
content mainly fitness mainly fitness um
I do a lot of like here's how to squat
videos to help people who are newer to
get into like understand how what to do
in the gym like when they're doing stuff
back in the day when I power lift it I
did like here's my prep for my
powerlifting meet and then you don't
consider yourself a power lifter anymore
I think I'll always be a power lifter
but at this current year I'm not
competing how much power do you need
like how much torque we're talking if
you can squat the bar then you can go to
a meet so I don't know how much torque
that well really just a bar that's all
you need what I thought about um like
whatever whenever I'm pregnant doing a
powerlifting meet and depending on how
pregnant I was it's not good to like be
in the prone position when you're
pregnant I guess which on your back but
I could just both are hard on certain
stages of pregnancy I think from what I
understand and I was like oh I could if
I'm like super pregnant that'd be cool
for a video definitely gonna pee on the
platform yeah for sure doing double
unders which is pregnant when a GP it's
a jump rope when the rope goes under
Taizo cuz a lot of people pee on those
oh no I probably pee now that's why I
collect a job yeah
do you feel the babies around I was
gonna ask that no because I mean you I
mean obviously because you train you're
getting everything really tight but man
I was so not like my core was so weak
that even going over speed bumps I felt
like the kid was gonna pop out of the
wall really yeah you're also like half
my size so that's probably a - maybe
yeah I mean Tycho is I do you feel the
baby Sasha I think huh did you feel the
baby sloshing well yeah over those speed
bumps I would feel like the pressure
like the kid going down like god damn
baby it go slow on these [ __ ] speed
bumps that's crazy
yeah well those are his feet he was
upside down he was upside down oh [ __ ]
yeah but you should do it you should try
to do it yeah he'll be cool are you
looking to get pregnant anytime soon I
just got engaged
[Applause]
but I want to get pregnant like today oh
really
today well you better you better go home
are you ovulating I'm not sure if I'm
waiting but I should use a nap but I
have been starting to use an app to
track thing I love it the guys are
saying all this terminology cuz my wife
how come how can you want to get
pregnant so fast cuz okay I'm 31
so I think I'm ready to like age wise I
wanna maybe I don't know we'll see how
the first one goes but I think maybe I
want to have two kids it's like I don't
want to be you know old I want to be
honest fun um but yeah I and now we're
talking about planning a wedding but
part of me is just like I want to do
something quick so I don't have a baby
didn't you need that video and that's
gonna go viral girl so you got to have
that kickflip you can use deep fakes on
your wedding video
[Music]